sam amick he writes for the athletic the
nba senior writer he was in attendance
for both games last night but let me
start with the headline here
steve nash going to the brooklyn nets as
a head coach
who saw this one coming sam
well we didn't my friend yeah dan they
they caught us off guard
um i love the pick to be honest with you
uh we all know
the relationship between steve and kevin
durant from the warriors days
i was around those teams a lot and i
tell you like i look at steve and it's
it's a genius move he laid in the
shadows and learned from people
after retirement uh obviously you know
with a guy that that wanted to
get on the sideline at some point but no
we didn't see it coming
and i do like it though and i love the
fact that jacques bond's still going to
be there
to be a major part of what they're doing
uh but i give it a big thumbs up
but explain that relationship with steve
nash and kevin durant
and golden state so kevin
you know is a guy who certainly kind of
gives a tip of the cap to the greats he
does talk to a lot of them
and is is a basketball scientist so to
speak and so steve and him
clicked a lot during the warriors days
forget steve's exact title it was
basically
consultant advisor but dear friend of
warriors coach steve kerrs
and somebody who you know when the
cameras weren't watching
would spend time in the off season would
spend time
intermittently during the season with
kevin and you know and
just vibing in the kind of way that only
so many people on this planet can
from a basketball perspective and i like
it for kevin because honestly i just
said this to somebody
in the chat i had you know most of his
warriors relationships
seemingly uh it kind of had the sense
that there was a burned bridge there
from that chapter
in his career and this is one of those
things where
i think it gives him a little piece of
kind of you know what he did when he
accomplished during that time
and and carries it over to this next
challenge and
you know and steve as far as people who
i've covered who you sit there and
listen to
and go yeah okay he's on a different
level i mean steve is on the short list
and so
i think he's probably going to be a very
good head coach what about with kyrie
irving i don't worry about durant
kyrie's always the question yeah no he
is
i mean you got the obvious which is the
point guard language that they can speak
um and you have steve's style which
in terms of personality uh
you know if anybody was going to be able
to withstand
you know kind of the highs and lows of
what come with kyrie irving
in terms of his makeup and his
personality i think steve's got that
relationship moxie now you know the
power stuff
the when they have tough times stuff uh
that would be the number one question
for me when
something really hard has got to be said
how does he say it how does he deliver
it um you know but he's gonna be
i do think a steve kerr kind of coach um
you know and so again the the connection
between kevin's warriors chapter and
this one is fascinating the kyrie thing
kyrie's got to fix his the optics that
surround him you know what i mean so
he's got a lot on the table too here
the rockets advance what do you think
the lakers reaction was to last night's
result
i don't feel like lebron might have been
disappointed
because his guy from a a personal
standpoint because his guy chris paul
almost shocked the world i mean i was
watching that game and dan you know we
don't root for anybody but
i gotta admit i'm watching this thing
going wow like is chris really gonna
get his revenge on the rockets and and
pull this thing off i mean
you know he's kind of talked about this
but people got to understand the degree
to which
he was upset about that trade so that
would have been a hell of a story
um but basketball wise you know i
honestly
if you're the lakers you got to be happy
you're not seeing defenders like luke
and thort
you know which is something i never
thought i would say a couple of months
ago um
you know he still barely pronounced the
guy's name and he was incredible
last night you know you got the rocket
star power but
i don't know they don't look great james
harden was terrible in game seven
offensively
uh and so you know i think if we're
doing the old prediction game i'd
probably go
you know lakers and six type of deal but
uh you know i think
the other thing is then the lakers have
been chilling like they've been hanging
out for
three days and i went to their practice
the other day and they were very low-key
and very light and it's
the kind of mood that is pretty tough to
come by in the bubble and and i
guarantee you that's going to
help them tomorrow finish this sentence
if the rockets had lost last night
well truthfully i think mikey and tony
is very likely gone anyway
so you know there's that element
um you know there's certainly just talk
around the league about daryl mori and
you know his future but he's got several
years on his contract that has been
every time i've tried to go straight to
the source on that one with the rockets
that has been shot down you know pretty
aggressively that that he's in trouble
um but you have the wild card of tillman
fertitta
who is an extremely emotional type of
owner that you know
the rockets owner who's been there a few
years now and who has seen
a lot of w's but you know seeing a lot
of playoff heartache so
i don't know what they would have done
with the roster james harden's not going
anywhere
and i don't think russ is either i think
they would probably keep writing it out
and just figure out you know what other
kind of around the edge improvements
they wanted to make
we're talking to sam amick he is nba
senior writer for the athletic who's in
more trouble
the milwaukee bucks or the toronto
raptors
i'm going to say the bucks i mean
they're both in big trouble uh the
raptors looked
a lot better in game two just didn't
pull it out um
the bucks honestly looked shook to me
and giannis in particular it's you know
i'm watching him last night and and it's
one of those moments in sports where
it's kind of you know you wish you could
be a fly on the wall inside of his own
brain and just what is he thinking
because
he doesn't look like uh like either he
or the group
have what it's going to take intensity
wise to
to get this miami team because jimmy
butler is a crazy person
and he's showing that right now and it
is contagious and bam out of bio who
honestly
i don't spend a ton of time around miami
because i'm based on the west coast
and i'm just really enjoying watching
some of their guys i mean tyler hero was
a lot of fun to watch
duncan robinson these are a bunch of
nobodies in terms of where they came
from
and that fits in with jimmy and
meanwhile i mean giannis even though
the giannis has got his own amazing rags
to riches story but
the bucks are the elite squad and they
look like
you know the the the heavyweight champ
that uh that didn't expect a fight like
this at all i think they're in big
trouble
i don't know if you saw the quote from
richard jefferson the former nba player
who said that
giannis is scottie pippen
yeah that's a little rough man for one
rj's good luck
finding michael jordan yes yeah
well and then you there's two sides to
that coin
because as we walked out of the arena
from that game last night
gary washburn and i from uh boston globe
were talking and
and we were saying like the chris
middleton question like the whole the
age-old question of who do you get
giannis is the number two
and i'm sitting there going yo like he
chris just had an incredible year he's
50 40 90 i mean it was
this is number two stuff um it's just
not happening
right now and the other hard part for
them the hypothetical of let's say they
actually get
beat here is they have created one of
the most unique and special cultures
in the league where everybody involved
loves the vibe and the culture that's
great but when it doesn't get you to the
result
if you move a chris middleton good luck
trying to figure out what
that means to giannis personally and and
how that impacts the culture there's
just a lot of layers to this thing
and i don't envy you know gm john horst
and coach mike budenholzer at all right
now and
they downplayed it last night and i get
it but man they they just acted like
this was nothing like okay it's two
games
and i'm sitting there going no this this
heap team is is not backing off so
i think they're in trouble yeah that's i
i viewed it the same way and
it's one thing to be a guy who puts up
great numbers there's regular season
numbers and then there's postseason
numbers
and i i need chris middleton to be
great in the postseason just like
anthony davis he didn't play any
meaningful games last meaningful game he
had prior this year was
probably at kentucky in the national
title game now you come in
hey i put up all these great numbers now
can you do it when the spotlight is on
you when everybody is watching
everything you do and describing
every and critiquing everything you do
we see guys who
love it grab it cherish it strangle it
and then the other guys who it just
consumes them
and that's what i don't know with the
greek freak or chris middleton
uh we've seen the raptors step up you
know fred van vliet doesn't
he's not afraid kyle lowry's not afraid
pascal ciaco has not stepped up
anthony davis has to step up paul george
is not step
kawhi loves this so you see playoff
basketball brings out the best and
sometimes the worst in players
100 i agree with all that and and to
take it back to giannis um
i i feel like when when i watched him in
october november and december he's
notorious for being
the guy who plays like it's the nba
finals even if it's a seating game even
if it's a preseason game
and he's you know his intensity level is
always very very high
so the downside of that is he sets the
bar so high on that front that i'm
watching him last night and just called
man like where
it's it's not there and it's because
he's frustrated it's because he's seeing
a wall
of heap defenders just because he can't
do what he does you know
you know coach budd had a line about how
giannis is he is being
honest and i'm sitting there going no
he's not he's not the same guy this guy
acted like it was meant you know men
amongst boys
for most of the year and and he's just
running into a wall right now
before i let you go uh who's in better
shape the lakers or clippers going into
the second round
um both pretty good i mean the lakers
getting
i do think they're going to have rondo
back and that matters a lot of folks
like to
kill rondo and say he's washed and say
he's not but he's part of the solution
for them
him not being there messed up their
lineups quite a bit and left them
searching
in the kinds of ways that killed their
shooting you know we don't equate rondo
with shooting but
there's you know i mean it's it's a low
bar but but him being
there is going to be big uh so i'll pick
the lakers but the clippers
are in good shape you know and and the
kawhi factor as you kind of alluded to a
second ago
is big it's pretty nice to have that one
dude that you know
is not going to be part of any of these
conversations about composure
or intensity he's just robotic about it
there's something and i brought this up
a couple of times
and i i don't know if anybody's ever
equated
kawhi in the way he plays to music but
there is a jazz feel to him
he's never in a hurry and there's a easy
flow to him that is rare to see in this
game
certainly when it comes to the playoffs
you buy into my felonious monk or
uh miles davis reference
yeah i do shameless plug a buddy of mine
wrote a book basketball and jazz david
thorpe a fantastic coach and
long-time media personality and kawhi
does play that way and
and you know like a jazz song you listen
to it and you're mellow and you're
enjoying it you're chilling
and next thing you know that puppy ramps
up and the drums start kicking in
and you know and and now it's a
different vibe and a different level
he's just unflappable uh and maybe more
so than anybody in the league
sam i hope you're doing well we
appreciate your time as always
you got it thanks dad thank you that's
sam amick he writes for the athletic nba
senior
writer